on va jouer aura pour tous tous pour
vous poser des questions par équipes
je vous dire on aura la table de droite
contre la table de gauche
d'accord il y aura des questions sur la
télévision et il y aura bien sûr des
galles il y a le roy de la pomme de
terre c'est s'asperger le visage avec un
brumisateur plus mettre sa tête dans une
assiette de flocons de purée ça c'est un
carton je les fais hier soir là où les
enfants étaient ol-om des fous il ya
également celle là elle est géniale et
je vous le dis juste ne mangeait pas les
glaces savent qu'elles ne sont pas
bonnes à feluy parce que vous allez
devoir faire la licorne glace et c'est à
dire vous allez aux lyonnais se mettre
un cône glacé sur le fond et imiter le
cheval et ya le bouche à bouffe c'est à
dire que là les quatre vous devrez vous
faire passer un oeuf frais avec la
bouche en sang le caf la première
question c'est pour vous là le seul
public tape des mains mais pour rire
pendant combien de temps ces crêtes
story était à l'antenne de nt1 mercredi
8h22 8h49
9h16 ou 10 heures soit le temps que mes
gilles verdez pour se moucher et 49 18
heures alors allez vous d'être une bonne
réponse le chef d'équipé requin c'est
mathieu ainsi mathieu gallet l'est tout
autant d'indirects lui annoncer qu'il
avait gagné au loto thé ses bois alors
matthew allez on dit 8h49
9h16 alors allez sur le 400 ha ouais bah
oui chef
et là on se dit que vers prendre la
chance va tomber gili va se promener 3
salive
[Applaudissements]
comme je suis sympa je vous le prouve
comme je suis sympa et je vous le dis ce
sont des loups
les regarder sa part
[Applaudissements]
alors ça va être maintenant pour
l'équipe un peu plus âgé quel jeu à
réaliser la plus forte audience à la
télévision française
que le meilleur gagne intervilles la
roue de la fortune ou l'académie des 9
sur nrj d'intervilles moi j'aimerais
c'est un prime est allé s'il vous plaît
une bonne réponse peut-être commis alors
le chef d'equipe le chef d'equipe c'est
julien ont d autre interview que le
meilleur gagne on va sur l'île
on va sur intervilles rey s'était comme
la mer vous faites au clavicorde en plus
aidé alors ne les mangent et pas après
parce que la glace est vraiment avoir
dit non mais je vous le dis d'accord à
100 vous devez là donc on communiquera
oui bah j'ai bien compris le principe
vous le faites mal à woods fait bien
allez merci
symbole
[Applaudissements]
à
je vais pas
dans la seine
[Musique]